on sleep
one of the cool things about the human
mind
when it sleeps is dreaming
what do you think we understand about
the contents of dreams like what do
dreams
mean all the stuff we see when we dream
is there
something that we understand about
uh the contents of dreams some of it is
very concrete so
matt wilson who mit guy um
showed in rodents and it's been shown in
non-human primates and now it's been
shown in humans that
there is replay of spatial information
during sleep
so initially what matt showed was that
as
these little rodents navigate through a
maze they're these cells in the
hippocampus called place cells that fire
when the animal encounters a turn or a
corridor and
that same exact same sequence as replay
during sleep
and it turns out this is true in
london taxi cab drivers before phones
and gps were what they are today
the london taxi cab drivers were famous
for knowing the routes through the city
through these mental maps and their
analysis of their place cell firing
during sleep and during wakefulness and
so we are essentially
taking spatial information about the
location of things and replaying it
during sleep however
it's not replayed so that you remember
it all it's replayed so that
if there's a reason to remember it the
links to the emotional system to the
components of the limbic system and
hypothalamus that are
relevant like you got into a car crash
or a particular location or you lost a
bunch of money because you were
a cab driver uber driver we'd say
nowadays and you were stuck at one
particular avenue all day and frustrated
and you're getting yelled at by your
spouse that information gets encoded
so that you never forget that at that
particular time of day in that
particular time of year
and this thing happened so context
starts getting linked to experience so
there's spatial information
that's absolutely replayed during sleep
and we experience this sometimes
as dreams the dreams that happen early
in the night when slow wave sleep or
non-rem sleep dominates
tends to be sleep of very kind of
general themes and kind of um
location it can feel a little bit eerie
and kind of strange ins
not so incidentally the early phase of
the night is when growth hormone is
released
in the 80s and 90s there was a drug that
was very popular it's very illegal now
called ghb
um you could actually buy it at gnc or
the store then i never took it but it
was a popular party drug and some people
some famous celebrities died while on
ghb
they were also on a bunch of other
things so it's not clear what killed
them but ghb
was very big in certain communities
because it promoted a massive release
of growth hormone and gave people these
very hypnotic states so people go to
clubs and they were in these very
hypnotic states it was part of a whole
culture
that's early night and those
dreams tend to not have a lot of
emotional content or load
that phase of dreaming is associated
with
the occasional jolting yourself out of
sleep because somewhat lighter sleep
this the dreams that occur during rem
during rapid eye movement sleeping that
dominate towards morning
are very different they tend to have
very little epinephrine is available in
the brain at that time
epinephrine again being this molecule
stress fear and excitement
you are paralyzed during these random
dreams you're you cannot move
there's intense emotion at the level of
what you're feeling and their so-called
theory of mind
theory of mind is an idea that was put
forward by simon baron cohen sasha baron
cohen's cousin
i think on the podcast i mistakenly said
that he was at oxford it's like the
cardinal sin he's at cambridge forgive
me i'm not british but
so the dreams in rem have are heavily
emotionally laden and it's very clear
that those
dreams and rem sleep if you deprive
yourself of them for too long
you become irritable and you start
linking
generally negative emotions to almost
everything
rem the dreams that occur in rem sleep
are when we divorce emotion from our
prior experiences
and it's when we extract general rules
and themes
uh mit seems to come up a lot today but
it's
it's highly relevant to suma tonagawa
nobel prize for
immunoglobulin but obviously fantastic
neuroscientists as well
has shown that the replay of neurons in
the hippocampus and elsewhere in the
brain
is kind of an approximation of the
previous episode
and a lot of fear unlearning of
uncoupling
emotion from hard or traumatic events
that happened previously occurs
in rem sleep so you don't want to
deprive yourself of rem sleep for too
long
and those dreams tend to be very intense
now epinephrine is low
so that you can't suddenly act out your
dreams but
what's interesting is sometimes people
will wake up suddenly
while in a rem dream and their heart
will be beating really really fast
that's a surge of epinephrine that
occurs
as you exit rem sleep so you were having
this intense emotional experience
without the fear
you were essentially going through
therapy in your sleep self-induced
therapy
it's like trauma therapy where you try
and divorce the emotion from the
experience
and then you wake up and some people
also have the other component of rem
which is atonia which is paralysis pot
smokers
experience this a lot more than non-pot
smokers there's an invasion of paralysis
into the waking state
i'm not a pot smoker but i have
experienced this and when you wake up
and you're paralyzed for a second
it's terrifying but then you jolt
yourself alert
so the rem sleep is important for
kind of the self-induced therapy and
forgetting the bad stuff
it's good for uncoupling the emotions
from bad experiences
and just there are two therapies i move
into sensitization reprocessing
which is a eye movement thing that shuts
down the amygdala
during therapy not during sleep and
ketamine which is a dissociative
analgesic it's actually very similar to
pcp and
ketamine is now being used as a trauma
therapy when someone comes into
the er for instance and they were in a
terrible car accident these are horrible
things to describe but you know
they saw a relative impaled on the
driving steering column or something
and they will give this drug to try and
shut off the emotion system
so that because they're not going to
forget let's be honest you don't forget
the bad stuff but
it is possible to uncouple the bad
events
from the emotional system and there's
all sorts of ethical issues about
whether or not that's good or bad to do
but
ptsd is a failure to uncouple the
emotion
from these intense experiences so the
goal of this kind of therapy
is in the uncoupling for that to be
permanent
yeah to uh to separate so they can
recount the event
and they can describe it without it
triggering the same somatic experience
of terror and dread
um because terror those feelings can be
debilitating obviously and you're saying
physiologically in uh rem sleep a
similar process is happening that's
right
that thematically rem sleep is about
experiencing
or replaying intense emotions without
experience the
somatic the physical component of the
emotion either the acting out
or the accelerated heart rate and
agitation
likewise with things like ketamine
therapies that's the idea is you're
uncoupling the physical sensation
from the mental events
you